it's finally here the first full-length
trailer for the hotly anticipated
Netflix show The Witcher based on
Andrzej Sapkowski book series of the
same name which has famously been
adapted into a collection of acclaimed
video games which as showrunner Lauren
Schmidt has Rick pulled the veil off the
footage at the Lucca comics & games
convention in Lucca Italy on October
31st all the major players of The
Witcher appear in this trailer including
of course Henry Cavill as Geralt of
Rivia the namesake Witcher who underwent
a number of mutations and was trained
from a very young age to develop
superhuman abilities to hunt monsters of
all sorts apart from doing what trailers
should do in laying the groundwork for
what the show is about and confirming
its December 20th release date the first
trailer for The Witcher includes several
small details sure to make fans of the
property smile and total Witcher newbies
get excited about the upcoming series in
the first few seconds of the trailer for
The Witcher the footage flashes to show
an extreme closeup of a violet colored
eye yennefer Zhai a skilled sorceress
and the eventual love of Geralt yennefer
is described in Cannon as having a Payoh
triangular face pilot eyes and narrow
slightly contorted lips networks and
showrunners have actually tried and
failed to bring violet eyed characters
to the small screen before but then
George RR Martin's Game of Thrones
novels each member of the royal
Targaryen family has purple eyes ranging
from pale lilac to deep indigo they
create a contrast with their pale white
sometimes silvery hair
HBO's television adaptation of Martin's
books got the hair right but the show up
did not to make the Targaryen xyce
violet not long after we've met with
yennefer striking purple gaze we see
something just as eye-catching in the
trailer for The Witcher a shots of
gerelds holding a metallic trinket in
his blood Kate and one may assume that
the object is Geralt sown white wolf
battalion that he can tuned to detect
beasts nearby but it isn't in actuality
its approach of princess rent-free who's
sort of a brutal badass version of Snow
White and the books later in the trailer
Geralt is shown riding on his horse
while another man walks beside him that
mystery man is Stan the lion a poet and
bard who offers quite a bit of comic
relief in the games in The Witcher Canon
dandelion becomes a close friend of
Geralt after the two meet during a
festival where dandelion was trying to
evade some particularly nasty dudes a
shot of the two in The Witcher trailer
does feature scenery that feels similar
to
subscribed in Sapkowski short story the
edge of the world which recounts
dandelions first meeting with gerelds so
it seems likely that the Netflix series
will indeed detail the pair's initial
meeting Geralt of Rivia offers some
powerful words in the middle of the
first full-length trailer but they
weren't written by the show's creative
team the short speech he gives in the
newly released footage has actually
taken almost verbatim from the short
story the last wish which precedes the
main witcher saga
Geralt says evil is evil lesser greater
middling it's all the same in the story
he goes on to say proportions are
negotiated boundaries blurred I'm not a
pious hermit I haven't done only good in
my life
but if I'm to choose between one evil
and another and I prefer not to choose
at all
and finally diehard Witcher enthusiasts
flip their lid over one particular
moment in the series trailer that casual
fans and those unfamiliar with the
property were probably a bit confused by
Geralt chillin in the bathtub his
medallion around his neck candles lit
behind him and he ennifer by his side
this isn't Netflix's attempt at using
Henry Cavill sex appeal to attract
audiences it's actually a near exact
replica of a cutscene from The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt the CD Projekt RED video game
released in 2015 that game showed Geralt
and supreme relaxation mode sitting in a
bathtub with his feet sticking out of
the basin bathtub Geralt became an
instant meme and was even turned into a
marvel see detailed hand-painted
statuette issued by Dark Horse judge me
he may not poke his toes out of the
water in the scene on Netflix his series
instead updating to be a little more -
more during his downtime but bathtub
Geralt is unequivocally here to stay all
the more reason to watch The Witcher
when it hits Netflix on December 20th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite Netflix originals are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bowel so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]